we've seen the somber walk before
but this impeachment delivered what the
last one lacked
mr asking you're recognized an opening
gut punch
a chilling montage from the crime scene
itself
you fight like hell and if you don't
fight like hell you're not going to have
a country anymore
that's a high crime and misdemeanor if
that's not
an impeachable offense then there is no
such thing
for this sequel it wasn't a foggy phone
call to ukraine in dispute
but whether or not a president incited
an insurrection
the defense tried to put the brakes on
from the start
arguing congress shouldn't even be
trying the case
now donald trump is a private citizen
presidents are impeachable because
presidents are removable
former presidents are not because they
cannot be
removed on this vote the age of 56
the days are 44. they lost their
constitutional case in a vote
now they'll have to rely on defending mr
trump's words before the siege
and his right to say them on a day many
members witnessed
up close it was surreal i mean i i'm
used to protests i'm used to freedom of
speech i'm used to people being angry
and being disruptive
i never realized how serious it was
you did not understand that until you
saw videos
the next day and days later but whatever
searing testimony there might be
here's the spoiler the senate will
almost certainly acquit
donald trump do you think ultimately
it's a good thing
that it's going ahead well i think it's
a good thing that we're
taking seriously the um very serious
events of january 6th
now the only president to have been
impeached twice whether he merits
conviction taking this
taking a look at this seriously i think
is worthy of the constitutional process
no one is expecting big concessions from
either side
but they do share one perspective
dragging this process out
could hurt them both cordelia lynch sky
news
washington